this is what I'm eating on my bulking
diet this is just my lunch introducing
carb City this is about the most
inefficient way to bulk that I have ever
seen to bulk you're going to want to
likely be in a chloric surplus with
carbs making up the majority of your
calories followed by protein and then
fat these two party size platters of
green vegetables are about as low
calorie and low carb as they come this
is also to maintain stable levels of
Baseline dopamine that's why I don't use
dressing and I don't use meat or fat one
of the main reasons why a lot of people
are not successful at bu all the fat and
protein mess up dopamine levels and they
don't have motivation to exercise with
authenticity the oh gosh no no no not
exercising authentically is definitely
not the reason why people have a hard
time bulking nor should you avoid
protein and fat in fact one amino acid
tyrosine which is found in Turkey beef
eggs dairy soy and legumes plays a
critical role in dopamine production
this video was so bizarre and
problematic next